no we're going to release the kraken or
the kraken or whatever
we're going to release a mythical sea
beast oh cool
that's cool i wish it was an actual like
kraken that would be cool
yeah it's just just a sea monster
awesome sea monster
that's why i have a big boat
well mike
i want to point i don't know if you saw
this but um
did you see that history was made this
weekend
see because like when you used to say
history was made
you know if this show was 20 years old
i'd say royce
let me guess we landed a rover on mars
we built a base on the moon right hey
vander vanderbilt was the first power
five uh football team to uh
to have a female player play cool
she was a kicker her name of course she
was a kicker royce what the [ __ ] else
she would she been
the [ __ ] quarterback the running back
linebacker let's get lindsay out there
to do defensive tackle
of course she's a kicker well not only
was she the first player to be
i'd feel like such [ __ ] if i was a
kicker like it's vanderbilt
she's a kicker for vanderbilt not only
was she a kick we're going to show the
kick here by the way we are going to
show it
um not only that but sarah fuller was
named the sec
special teams player of the week mike
let me guess let me guess let me guess
63-yard field goal to win a game right
like so
do you think she kicked a vehicle wait
she did
she did one kickoff she didn't even wait
a minute
one kickoff i was waiting i was waiting
for royce
i was waiting for royce to say something
like
20 yards 15 yards
20 yards no she didn't even get a field
goal
no she had one kickoff after halftime
she kicked the ball off
so let me just because yeah i'm not
going to pretend like i'm a big football
expert but
um let's say i'm in special teams on
another team in the sec
and i caught a kick off
and i ran it back for three yards
i would have already been a better
special teams player right
well if you had a vagina you would have
[ __ ] won the scc special team player
of the week
like don't you like mind you the scc is
huge powerful i mean
we're talking about some really good
teams are in there uh vanderbilt by the
way vanderbilt
fan the team she was on vanderbilt lost
41-0
does everybody like does everybody just
want to be treated like condescendingly
like is this where we're headed
well mike
she was named the sec special teams
player of the week at least the kickoff
she had must have been
[ __ ] glorious right it must have been
beautiful for for sct sec special teams
of the week that ball better land in
iran and explode
sure i guess and there she is wearing
number 32
jersey number in just six days i don't
know but it's used the same showers
was winning an sec soccer tournament
championship in orange beach alabama
and would you know it history is
on the field in columbia missouri as
sarah fuller is about to put her right
foot
into a football speaking vulnerabilities
around the world they built her up get
ready
all right it's better get ready here it
comes baby
player of the week player of the week
baby here we go
here it comes history about to be made
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know what that looks like it looks
like you know what you know what i got
lucky
it went uh well 40 yards and it
wobbled you know all right you know like
when the local high school
to get some good press they let like you
know some kid with down syndrome like do
one
play real quick so they can get in the
local news
that's what it's like they let one of
the down syndrome students do the
kickoff well there's something else i
want to show you we're going to play it
again but i want
to i need you to watch it through the
end of the play because something else
happens
watch this history is on the field in
columbia missouri
somebody says wait was it an on-site
kick if it was an on-site kick
it was also a terrible on-site no matter
what way people because they've been
trying people been coping with this kick
if it was an on-site kicker you'd only
kick it 10 yards right in front of you
so someone could
awesome awesome you can hit a crowd
everybody understands what's happening
right now women just look silly in
football gear like it just looks
silly or in positions of power pretty
cool this looks so silly
so she doesn't have to wear a cup at
least so uh
she kicks hit down at the 30. she didn't
even she ran right off the field after
the kick she didn't even run down like
every kicker runs down they for make a
tackle they don't want her
she ran she runs right off
the field so she ran right off the field
so she wants to be a football player
but she doesn't want to be a football
player so basically every other thing
that women want to do in life
right they want equality but they don't
really want equality they just want the
job and then you're going to do all the
work
they want equality but i like when it
involves have heavy lifting but like
but then look at like then this is just
layers of logistics that are unnecessary
for this team says
play like a girl but girls don't play
well you just
illustrated that play poorly why why are
no
look man why are we doing this
culturally why are we doing this
why are we lying to ourselves
i i i i i it boggles my mind
like i'm getting genuinely upset like i
know the kick is funny
and i know it's funny to just laugh at
girls because you know they're all
terrible
but i mean this is weird this isn't good
this isn't a healthy way to be right
like we're just denying reality can i
ask you a question
so you're saying that wasn't the sec
special teams play of the player of the
week
royce literally any other special teams
play in the sec this weekend had to be
better than that any literally anyone
so you're saying it wasn't sight unseen
i'd pick another one
why are we doing like why play like a
girl and then you just do it terrible
like why are we doing this
ladies you're giving up your sports
and then you're trying to move into
men's sports and
you're so short-sighted that you don't
realize that you're just gonna get
[ __ ] dominated at everything
we gave you your own separate leagues
so you could pretend to excel at
something that's
you wnba the the w uh what's the golf
one
all that [ __ ] pga we gave you all of
that lingerie football league so you
could live
feeling like you're good at something
despite not
being good at something hey remember
remember the woman's uh fema the female
soccer team that lost a bunch of 15 year
old boys
because that happened did that really
happen yeah the uh the usa
uh the usa olympic team uh
lost to uh 15 year old boys
in an exhibition game i believe that and
it's because
look you we we gave you like hey
go here we'll have a whole girls league
we'll even pay you guys like
250 000 a year for the top players like
we were really generous
and then you you did this weird thing
where
you linked up with the lgbtq community
you let trans people move into girls
sports
you're losing at that now so now you're
going to push your way into mail sports
and you're going to half-ass kick a ball
and then run off the field because
people are being told
that this is real like people are people
have to look at the
sec player of the week and you just have
to accept it
and and some people are like you know
what i'd rather shoot fentanyl into my
dick vain
um g police is right it's beyond parody
it's i i f this
it's not a good way to be when some of
the people that i know that
i consider to be normal good
godly folk people are being gaslit
into thinking they're crazy but
you're not i'm telling you if you think
this is a joke
then you're not crazy they're crazy
they're crazy you're not crazy don't let
them make you think you're crazy because
you're not
uh just so you know that there's a
football player named cadarius tony that
ran back
a was like a 70 yard punt return i know
his name's cadarius
i was gonna guess at least 70 yards and
does he have an apostrophe in his name
he had to share the
sec special teams player of the week
with that kick you saw are you kidding
me i'm looking at up now
uh kedarius tony had a punt return for
florida
and he has to share it with that squib
kick yes
so i just want to make sure that we're
all on the same page here so due to the
extremely baffling and downright
satirical beliefs of the far
left a a young black man
now has to share his accomplishments
with a white woman
yes i swear to god see ladies
do you understand why i hate you at
least i'm not saying you got to agree
with me
okay you can zoom or shoot swim it's
fine whatever but can you at least
see where i'm coming from could you just
maybe see it my way a little bit
this is a little bit
kedarius tony not only not only returns
he's
he's the first player uh
to return a 50-yard touchdown to return
a punt for 50 yards and then also get a
touchdown in the game
and he shared it with the worst kick
i've
ever seen i i i it's it's [ __ ]
it's comical man it's like
do you just do you understand
why some of us might hate your guts
hold on you got shields man that's a
replay let's just watch the replay real
quick
that was pretty cool that's pretty
awesome to see
by the way kedarius smith or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is
this is it for him this is all he's got
in gainesville but yes
gainesville i'm sorry no okay but you
know what i mean this is all he's got
man
let kedarius with an apostrophe in his
name have the one thing
let his family have one thing they can
hang on the refrigerator that isn't
riddled with misspellings
okay what about sarah fuller though it's
just oh
i can't take it i got chills man i got
chills man
he had chills me that was pretty cool
that was pretty awesome that was pretty
cool that's what you say
that's what you say like if i pulled out
a skateboard right now
then i went yo check this out and i
tried to do an ollie and tripped
royce would go wow man yes real cool
like that's what you say
somebody pointed out at least rudy got a
tackle it's
at least rudy tackled somebody oh [ __ ]
i i yeah any and then he [ __ ] dropped
that ring into the
lava and saved the world so i mean rudy
is cool
so um that's that was it i was an actor
he's an actor oh she wasn't the same guy
middle earth
so he didn't so then he did the so then
rudy's fake story that guy didn't really
do the football thing no no no no the
real
actor no the real guy there was really a
guy named rudy that really did that
so there was really a guy that dropped
the ring no
fictional like a woman playing football
well
i wanna i wanna wake up from this
nightmare
i just wanna wake up from this nightmare
nope ain't gonna happen my friend
ain't gonna happen